c'est sous un soleil magnifique s'est
déroulé ce jeudi 25 mai le trophée Sport
Passion au yogolf de Feucherolles comme
d'habitude les sportifs de haut niveau
avaient rendez-vous pour des parties de
golf mais cet événement qui fête cette
année son 30e anniversaire a aussi une
vocation solidaire autour sur la 30e
édition
[Musique]
et derrière le trophée Sport Passion
régime Gandolfini bien sûr bonjour
Régine bonjour on pouvait pas rêver
mieux pour la 30e édition du Trophée
Sport Passion au niveau du temps ou au
niveau des participants au niveau des
participants mais là je me référais
effectivement autant qui est magnifique
aujourd'hui à Feucherolles il fait très
très beau on est content bon un petit
peu froid mais la température va monter
ça va être très bien et de toute façon
pour jouer il vaut mieux ne pas avoir
trop chaud donc ça va très bien elle est
particulière je le disais 30e
anniversaire cette année du Trophée
Sport Passion ça représente quoi pour
vous de passer ce cap des 30 ans
rien
c'est voilà c'est c'est assez étonnant
et j'ai l'impression que ça ça perturbe
plus les gens qui étaient là il y a 30
ans où il y a 29 ans et qui me disent tu
te rends compte ça fait 30 ans pour moi
ça a été une année après une année après
une année je dirais que pendant les
10 15 premières années c'était à chaque
fois de me dire est-ce que je réussirai
à le faire l'année prochaine tellement
c'était compliqué sur un plan économique
en fait d'organiser un trophée comme
celui-là et depuis que je suis
accompagnée par le Conseil départemental
des Yvelines et par notre partenaire
testo qui était là depuis très très
longtemps ça a été plus de se dire
maintenant
on est on est dans la dans la dans la
poursuite dans la durée de l'événement
et avec des habitués vous le dites il y
a aussi des des nouveaux venus qu'est-ce
qui fait la réussite vous l'avez dit
c'est de se retrouver sur une journée il
y a un public fidèle mais aussi de
nouveaux venus qui qui viennent aussi
sur sur ce trophée Sport Passion on en a
oui alors on a je dirais fidèle quand
ils peuvent se libérer ils sont ils le
notent ils sont là donc ça c'est très
important tout à l'heure je parle avec
Philippe Candeloro et il me disait tu te
rends compte on a vieilli quand même été
dit on a vieilli mais c'est incroyable
quand même 30 ans et il me dit comment
tu as fait il m'a posé la question
Philippe et je lui ai dit mais j'ai
réussi à grâce à toi toi et d'autres
parce que quand vous vous venez pour moi
vous êtes comme des Ethem c'est sur les
bateaux c'est je suis étayée par eux en
fait par ces sportifs qui sont très
connus qui m'aident après les nouveaux
c'est peut-être parce qu'il se disent
euh bah le golf je connais je joue et
j'ai envie de participer une journée de
golf ou je connais pas et j'ai envie de
découvrir donc ça c'est important et
c'est aussi de se dire bah j'ai envie de
voir les autres et forcément le fil
rouge de la journée c'est le golf mais
il y a aussi des animations là
aujourd'hui quel est le programme des
animations du jour alors on a donc on
soutient depuis maintenant 4-5 ans une
fédération sportive qui s'appelle
eufolep donc fédération
multisport qui permet qui travaille
beaucoup pour des jeunes vers le sport
ils font beaucoup beaucoup de travail
social pour pouvoir amener les gens à
faire du sport ça peut être des adultes
également et donc nous on les soutient
grâce aux conseils départemental on leur
donne un chèque de 4000 € chaque année
donc ils nous ont mis un mur d'escalade
on a du panafoot qui va être là on a du
drone soccer et nous mettre de leidens
enfin il y a plein plein d'animations
toute l'après-midi qui vont être mises
en place à qui commence et qui vont
durer jusqu'à ce soir alors vous l'avez
dit elle sera ma dernière question 30
ans finalement c'est qu'un chiffre pour
vous on lui souhaite quoi au Trophée
Sport Passion 30 ans supplémentaires
pourquoi pas avec avec une transmission
bien sûr parce que moi dans 30 ans je
sais pas mais non j'ai envie de dire pas
30 ans supplémentaires de à l'année
prochaine merci Régine Gandolfini très
bon anniversaire pour ses 30 ans du
Trophée Sport Passion où on va aller à
présent à la rencontre des sportifs qui
étaient présents sur cette journée
et comme le disait Régine Gandolfini à
côté des parties de golf également des
animations qui sont assurés en plus par
les sportifs qui sont présents notamment
par Cyril carré bonjour bonjour alors
cet après-midi vous allez faire vous une
initiation enfin vous avez ramener votre
kayak et vous allez pouvoir faire
découvrir le kayak aux personnes
présentes oui ça c'est ça ça s'est prévu
au dernier moment j'ai proposé d'amener
mon kayak de course donc ça va être une
animation sympa à regarder c'est un
bateau très instable donc on va voir les
plus à l'aise dessus en général ça dure
pas plus d'un coup de Paillé mais
certaines
certains pratiquants sportifs notamment
sur la gym sont plus à l'aise sur sur ce
genre d'embarcation quand on a de la
force on essaie de l'utiliser ça finit à
l'eau tout de suite et mais voilà c'est
une première approche
finalement dans l'après-midi pas
d'activités kayak sur ce plan d'eau du
yogolf de Feucherolles en raison de la
présence au fond de ce plan d'eau d'une
bâche qui risquerait de se percer en cas
de chute à l'eau mais l'après-midi à
Feucherolles a été égayé par d'autres
activités il y avait notamment de
l'escalade de vitesse avec le champion
Guillaume Moreau alors là j'ai vu qu'il
y avait un mur derrière moi qui doit
faire à peu près 8 mètres moi je
m'entraîne sur un mur de 15 m c'est un
mur homologué avec une homologuée mais
là ça va être l'occasion de montrer ce
que je vois sur un autre mur donc de
l'escalade de vitesse c'est bien ça
ouais escalade de vitesse qui sera donc
à Paris 2024 pour les JO et qui était
qui est rentré à Tokyo pour la première
fois dans le programme des JO allez
allez allez
enfin pas en avant
allez allez c'est parti
et l'après-midi du Trophée Sport Passion
vous l'avez vu à recommencer avec un
haka qui a été mené par ces deux hommes
par Joël abati et Antoine Kombouaré Joël
d'abord bonjour monsieur
racontez-nous déjà le haka c'est un caca
kanak qui me semble c'est ça
en parler parce que il est né dedans et
on voit que la sagesse qu'il a et la
force qu'il a ça vient de là-bas aussi
c'est le haka donc du Pacifique mais
après nous on l'a on l'a modifié un peu
on a fait ça à notre sauce et donc ça
fait un truc très sympa donc puis
surtout pour que tout le monde puisse
vivre c'est ça
il y a des conditions idéales pour fêter
le 30e anniversaire du Trophée Sport
Passion tout le temps le soleil tout est
parfait pour une belle compétition et
puis on a un parrain admirable très je
lui dis en face parce que j'ai une très
grande fierté pour ce qu'il a fait dans
sa carrière et puisqu'il a fait après il
était là au départ aussi parce que moi
je suis arrivé par la suite mais Antoine
a été là au départ et c'est une idée
magnifique de tous ces sportifs de
partager leurs performances la passion
autour du golf c'est l'idée de partager
l'idée de se retrouver et puis en plus
il y a le golf la partie mais surtout le
plus important c'est après la soirée où
là on se retrouve et puis tous les
sportifs on parle de nos différentes
expériences et tout et puis on apprend
toujours de l'autre et donc on échange
et c'est surtout des moments très sympa
parce que après quand on repart d'ici on
se suit voilà on suit nos parcours tout
ça et tout et là donc moi ça fait 30 ans
on était voilà au départ et de me
retrouver ici pour le 30e anniversaire
c'est souvent émouvant pour moi et c'est
émouvant pour vous d'être le parrain
justement de la 30e
moi j'ai heureusement qu'elle m'a appris
donc au dernier moment parce que non moi
je vois moi j'aime bien moi j'aime bien
venir tranquille dans la discrétion mais
alors c'est c'est le 30e anniversaire et
c'est vrai que moi je fais partie des
membres fondateurs donc voilà je me
devais donc d'assumer cette instabilité
mais ce soir je vais demander surtout
donc à beaucoup de gens de venir là et
puis m'accompagner parce que je serai
pas seul quoi on est plusieurs parents
dans Joël je vais le on souhaite quoi au
Trophée Sport Passion ah ben que vive la
passion et surtout que vénissent
s'amuser partager c'est ce qu'on a
besoin aujourd'hui en tout de nous le
mot de la fin Antoine non que surtout
les joies les gens pardon soit heureux
quoi passe une belle journée et puis
surtout donc ce soir qu'on vienne fêter
ça autour d'un verre moi c'est ce que je
souhaite vraiment ah non pas douter donc
encore de belles longues années pour le
Trophée Sport Passion rendez-vous
l'année prochaine pour la 31e édition